ich stehe hier mit marc pitzke gerade
mit seinem bruder im internet ist ein
bisschen weiter dort hinten an dem
wohnhaus nicht wollte die gelegenheit
nutzen wladimir wenn sie das sehen diese
zerstörung hier dieses wohnhauses was
macht das mit dir wie hast du das erlebt
was
krieg
erzählt prozent
es ist einfach keine könig punkt und
zivilbevölkerung
integrierter leben wir das immer wieder
die viele
wohnhäuser angegriffen werden wir leben
russische raketen überall in der ukraine
und gleichzeitig sagen platin politik
immer noch nein es würden nur
militärische ziele angegriffen
widerspricht laut als jede wohl was sie
verstecke
die russische mir sorgen was sollte die
welt tun sie lenski verlangt immer noch
ja danach dass der luftraum geschlossen
werden müsse das ist eine
flugverbotszone gibt es auch mitspielen
in der ganzen welt in kontakt und stehst
mit bieren auch amerikanern in kontakt
siehst du irgendwie eine chance dafür
diese krieg muss gestoppt werden
wir reden hören explosion
wahrscheinlich zehn kilometer weit weg
während wesen werden weit mehr zivilist
getötet
ukraine werden getötet die sinnlose mit
ihrem grab mit geschlossenem elegisches
label mit beteiligungs waffen die die
ukraine braucht mit dimensionen mit
dieser isolation und russland ist
wirtschaftlich in starken funktion mit
ihrer art und weise diese sinnlose krieg
muss gestoppt werden das ist du weißt du
für die bilder sprechen lauter ist jede
bord
spricht dafür dass dieser krieg ist
gegen die ukrainische volk hören jetzt
auch wieder anschläge am ende
wahrscheinlich abwehr von raketen es
dass man nur das ständig in der stadt
die frauen sozusagen oder die ja aus
chemikern immer näher eine stadion der
stehen dicht die ganz explosionen und
noch einmal
mit ihrem
besten gewählt die partner von ukraine
müssen putins krieg stoppen es macht gar
kein sehen nicht nur die infrastruktur
wird zerstört in diesem land die
menschen werden kontinuierlich
easy creek gestoppt werden gibt es etwas
ganz spezielles aus deutscher sicht was
passieren muss wir sehen das in
deutschland immer noch kein öl und gas
embargo bis zum beispiel weitere
sanktionen isolation ist schattig ist
weil das was wir gerade sehen der für
werden die russen das geht aus die idee
war
die zu stark es gibt nichts kreatives
was aus der evolution platte kommt nur
destruktives
entweder propaganda wo die menschen
einfach verlieren kompletten gesicht wie
die welt aussieht vor allem wie die welt
ihnen durch renault aussieht es herrscht
den krieg
siehst du irgendeine chance für die
friedensverhandlungen zwischen putin und
szenen ski
ich wünsche mir und hugh greene ist es
die chancen stehen
wie das gemacht wird dass wir schon
sehen während geradelt wird
beide geschosse hört abgefeuert wurden
es muss nur einmal ich wiederhole ist
immer wieder auch die durch regierung
muss die ukraine unterstützen und
russland diese lehre scharfe resolution
schild diesen krieg zu stoppen
vielen dank
wir gehen mal einmal ein stück weiter
näher an wir sehen jetzt hier
aufräumarbeiten bereit an dieser ecke
ich schaue ich zeige euch noch einmal
wie es hier weiter aus die dringend
einmal in die richtung wo jetzt der
bürgermeister
peter ditsch sei eine art
pressekonferenz ich habe deswegen gerade
etwa mich kurz mit wladimir unterhalten
wir sehen hier viele journalisten
und hier ist der vorgang weiter bisher
liegt mit sport
dass alle demokratischen staaten müssen
ja patricia und kann mit diesen bildern
aus dem
zerstörten
gebäude hier wo jetzt
aufkommen arbeiten stattfinden
ewig einmal zurück zu euch nach
berlin